all right our first mascot can usually
be seen smashing through brick walls but
not today because he's fallen victim to
this year's bad flu season that's right
it's kool-aid man with the flu man with
the flu he's not looking too good
he's a nice blanket he's got a fever
he's doing the best he can he's having a
lot of liquids who a man with the flu
try and dunk that basketball
[Applause]
didn't quite make it hey kool-aid man
and there goes shoot the diseased calf
Chan that's alright next we have a duo
who usually don't get along but today
they've agreed to work together that's
right it's the hunter and the bear in a
three-legged race let's get him out here
get your hunter you got your they are
tied together the one time they're
joining forces and let's see if they can
work together and dump that basketball
go
[Applause]
that was impressive
that was amazing all right look and
there's still friends tomorrow one will
kill the other
our next mascot is a beloved staple from
the animated world that's right it's the
cartoon character who has just eaten a
hot pepper the cartoon character who is
a hot pepper we've seen him in many
cartoons let that that's a basketball
there dude
all right cartoon characters you seen
the hot pepper can you dunk that
basketball go
[Applause]
he completely missed the bag did you see
that he slid off the pad and he landed I
think he's lucky I think he bit his
tongue off
our next mascot was never meant to be
discovered that's right it's your dad's
old porn stash here there's your dad
[Applause]
time you found it in the basement
these porno magazines have not been in
subscription for a long time yeah
memory lane that was a good one okay
your dad's embarrassed that he's out
here but let's see if the porn stash can
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
watching them get up and move away as
the saddest thing I've seen in many
years
our next mascot is a beautiful tribute
to the amazing circle of life that's
right it's miss pac-man in labor miss
pac-man and labor here is Miss that's
right you asked for it you got it
[Applause]
there's no way this is gonna win this
black man and wait for Joe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for you you have to separate them from
the mom immediately our final mascot is
a perennial favorite he's back for his
third attempt to dunk
please welcome shrunken head Shaq
yes fruit cannerts at truncated chat
which is your third chance truncated
check let's see if you can do it let's
get behind him folks
[Applause]
[Music]
how close was he
I'm sorry we're just gonna have to bring
him back next year all right I'm sorry
yeah yeah let's hear it again for the
n-c-double-a mascots that should never
dunk
you